there's a growing sense that war-torn
Syria is entering a new phase that could
mean new opportunities but also new
dangers well the situation on the ground
changed dramatically when US President
Donald Trump made the unexpected
decision to in large measure at least
withdraw American forces from Syria in
doing so the Americans abandoned their
erstwhile allies the Kurds Russia and
Turkey have stepped into the vacuum with
Vladimir Putin and wretched tire
Bedouins appearing to be the key players
in the region it's certainly a volatile
situation and we ask old faces new
alliances who will win the battle for
Syria
[Music]
well thanks very much for joining us
here on the show and my panel is made up
of three guests here they are beginning
with Christine Helberg a featured Mid
East analyst with a number of European
publications she says with his plan for
northeastern Syria Putin has made both
air21 and Assad happy
it's the Kurds who are paying the price
also with this Alan Posner a regular
commentator for the berlin-based daily
developed who argues Russia and Iran
have already won the struggle for Syria
now it's important for the West not to
lose Turkey and a warm welcome to to
Chari as Damir formed ews turkish
department he believes turkey's only
game is syria now is to contain the
perceived security threats and help
assad remain in power to begin with you
and ask you i mean it's been a really
torrid week in syria once again and i'd
like to ask you to if you would sort of
map out where we find ourselves now at
the end of that torrid week and where
this is leading for the the cruelly
pushed Syrian people yes I mean the
battle for Syria is decided I would
argue you know Bashar Assad the Syrian
president won the war militarily with
the help of Vladimir Putin
he just militarily won the war he is
regaining control of the last remaining
regions which is it lipped to the west
with military force with the support of
the Russian Air Force basically and the
Northeast which he will go back to
smoothly and by doing so destroying
Kurdish autonomy so it's decided to this
extent and Vladimir Putin is the big guy
who holds all the strings in the back
all industries pulling the strings and
he does so very cleverly because now he
gave errands to some extent what she
wanted an area inside Syria to resettle
Syrian refugees to control it to maybe
build some kind of other Turkish
Protectorate and giving the whole
Northeast back to Bashar al-assad as I
just lined out but the problem of
Vladimir Putin is the following
he kept Assad in power but he has not
the financial means to stabilize the
regime so this is why he needs something
that looks like a political solution to
make the West pay for reconstruction and
to normalize relations with Damascus so
that's the big plan of Putin now how to
get a political solution or something
that looks so to make everybody
reconciliate with Assad okay very
fascinating insights to begin with Chava
as tamiya give us an idea of what the
Turkish people are saying about the
latest developments about Turkey having
such a central presence now in Syria the
situation in Turkey is quite like there
is only one voice about what's going on
in Syria and that is pretty much
consolidated by the fact that the media
is pretty much consolidated under the
influence of the government so when the
incursion started apart from the
pro-kurdish party HDP almost everybody
in Turkey was kind of line up behind
either on including the main opposition
party including the voices that we were
thinking that would kind of challenge
Ireland in the future they were just all
Pro incursion and that is mostly because
of the fact that this operation is being
perceived as a as a vital threat to
Turkey like a threat that would put
Turkish lives at risk so people kind of
went up after the army and then said
that we're all supporting the incursion
maybe on the long term not the political
repercussions of it but when it comes to
the security on the border yes there was
this huge consensus in the country which
is very surprising considering the the
reactions coming from the other parts of
the world do they have to be concerns
about the fact that Bashar al-assad is
now resurgent as we just heard from
Kristen and there have already been
clashes between Turkish units and Syrian
regime units yeah well those clashes
were mostly turkey supported militia
units and they're like just reports and
we don't know for a fact at the moment
and those skirmishes could happen
because it's a war zone and in those
these things always happen it doesn't
mean that the Turkish army is fighting
Bashar al-assad's army at the moment but
I think what is going on in Turkey at
the moment on the political level as
well on the societal level is that
people are focusing on the short-term
outcomes of the operation rather than
the long-term outcomes and we need to
have a healthy environment to discuss
all the aspects of these and I don't
think it's being discussed widely at the
moment in Turkey because of the
political atmosphere
okie-dokie a new stage in Syria's recent
history now question mark well obviously
in a new stage in the history of the
whole region because basically from what
when the British were through in 48 till
just recently America was the only name
in the game it was the power broker that
for all the you know the
egyptian-israeli reconciliation for most
everything and now and and after the and
now the only name of the game is
Vladimir Putin and maybe the people in
Iran this is an incredible it's a
geopolitical shift of him and and we
have in the case of Turkey a NATO member
going openly against the wishes of its
partners to align itself with with
Russia which we consider an adversary
this is you it's it's it's huge it's not
just serious the whole region and the
Europeans should adapt very quickly to
this fact that the US are out of the
game of the Middle East and they are not
even very much they don't have a lot of
effects from the problems in the Middle
East contrary to Europe you know all the
all the consequences will be felt inside
Europe and as mr. Trump rightfully
pointed out that the u.s. is 10,000
kilometers far away and we are just
neighbors so it's up to the Europeans to
think more not in a long-term
perspective and to formulate visions and
interests in the region and how to put
them forward and I know a lot of the
attention this past week has inevitably
been devoted to the death of Abu Bakr
al-baghdadi the leader of the so-called
Islamic state apparently took his own
life after being hunted down by US
Special Forces
what exactly made him so important in
the end all that was left of the world's
most wanted terrorists was a gaping
crater Abu Bakr al-baghdadi
self-appointed caliph of the Islamic
state terrorist group was no charismatic
leader when compared to al-qaeda leader
Osama bin Laden who was killed in
Afghanistan in 2011 by a US military
special operations unit well al Baghdadi
locked in public image he more than made
up for in brutality he bears
responsibility for thousands of deaths
torture enslavement and attacks by Isis
the world over u.s. President Donald
Trump was unabashedly triumphant when he
announced al-baghdadi is killing he died
like a dog he died like a coward the
world is now a much safer place and
security analysts have little doubt that
Isis has enough financial means and
fighters to pose a continuing threat has
al Baghdadi's death really made the
world a safer place chose Damir what's
your answer to that question Donald
Trump says the world is a safer place is
it well in the short term it might
appear to be so because Isis has been
already disorganized for the past few
good months and and and it couldn't
carry out the attacks that it used to
and the difference the main difference
between Isis and and the organizations
like al-qaeda was that Isis controlled a
swath of territory for you know a few
good years so in that sense I think
Baghdad is death is a setback for Isis
in general but the ideology is there or
the conditions at which people choose to
join Isis and choose to fight against
what they claim to be threats against
Islam and and the rest are gonna be
there it's not going to go anywhere
because the dude's horses the the
conditions that create Isis remains the
same in the in the end of the day
Christian you have been nothing
yes I completely agree with that it's
you know the the ground for extremist
organization is very fertile all over
the region you know without perspective
economic perspectives with the sense of
humiliation you know not the option for
political participation this is these
are all conditions that create a fertile
ground for any kind of extremist
organization and Isis has not
disappeared even in Syria we have almost
on a daily level we have in the
Northeast we had attacks car bombs
whatever so here they have just gone
underground and they now use the chaos
that was created by the Turkish invasion
you know to break out of these prisons
to reorganize themselves and to yes to
kind of reorganize themselves and to
recruit among the people that are there
are a lot of family members around there
so they will just they will start to be
another force there and they don't
they're not disappearing and I don't
think that the world is a lot more safer
now what about Donald Trump what's
what's his position now alone I don't
quite get it he's ordered this mission
against Baghdadi he's wallowed in the
success of the mission does that mean
that he has learned the error of his
ways in initially appearing to withdraw
US forces completely from Syria no I
think that's an aberration I mean they
had the opportunity they've been
planning this for a long time for months
and they and they carried it out with
panache I mean hats off to the u.s.
special forces and to the people who
help them every dead terrorist is a good
terrorist but the the the the fact is
that on the one hand he does this and on
the other hand as has been pointed out
he pulls out of an area leaving the
Kurds who are guarding thousands if not
more of Isis terrorists in the lurch
they're deserting these camps of course
because they have to fight or have to
leave the region and these terrorists
are gonna come back home not the United
States to Europe and the fact is that
Donald Trump has decided to cut his
losses in the Middle East he's decided
we spent five trillion dollars there
we've lost 7,000 men we're gonna go home
and leave it to the rest of the world
sorted out he said he said oh these
people have to fight it out it's like
two kids on a school in a school ground
you have to let them fight well it's
gonna be like that it might look that
way from Washington but it's not gonna
be like that for us because these Isis
terrorists are gonna come home to us if
the if if Russia calls the shots in the
Middle East we're gonna see the
consequences in myriad ways they're
going to assert themselves more in
Europe later too and so on and so on and
so on
and we didn't even take responsibility
for their Isis fighters that have our
nationalities right you're talking about
eighty-four German Isis fighters in the
family members a third of them is
considered to be dangerous dangerous so
we should have taken them before this is
what the Kurds asked us for this is what
Dona Trump asked us for and we still try
to you know keep them away you know to
and now they will come in an in a
regulated way which makes it even more
dangerous the Americans got permission
from the Russians to use the airspace
that they control to carry out the
Baghdadi mission what does that tell us
about the bizarre and often unfathomable
relationship between Vladimir Putin and
Donald Trump at this point in time but
when it comes to terrorism they are
ready to cooperate but it's very
interesting to discuss where he was
hiding he was hiding in the north and
part of Italy five kilometers away from
Turkey turkey is supposed to control
this area with 13 observation posts I
don't Gavin I personally cannot
speculate on that whether turkey had the
Intel that he was hiding over there or
not they might have some Intel about it
but we shouldn't forget the fact that
for the government in Turkey the
priority at the moment is Syrian
democratic forces or half turkey causes
YPG so Isis has always been a threat to
Turkey it carried out attacks in Turkey
it killed so many people incurred in
Turkey as well but at the end of the day
it's the YPG that Turkey is prioritizing
its mission into so and it was turkey
who led all these foreign fighters pass
through Turkey to reach ice yeah during
yeah during the war yes he also stated
the Syrian opposition to take part in
the in the northern Syria okay lots of
speculation one thing is for sure
developments in recent weeks have
certainly played into the hands of
Vladimir Putin as we see now turkish
president rachel te arawa needed a favor
from russian president putin
turkey a NATO partner found itself
asking its old foe Russia for permission
to intervene militarily in northern
Syria the images make plain the new
balance of power in the region Vladimir
Putin's Russia is now the dominant
peacekeeper in Syria the agreement
between Putin and erawan gives a boost
to Syrian President Bashar al-assad
through him Putin can secure his
position in the region in return Assad's
getting nearly one third of his
territory back while he stations troops
along the Turkish border in the north
after withdrawing its forces the United
States has virtually no part left to
play is the u.s. fading to a regional
power while Russia returns as a world
power we looked at that already let's
just talk a little bit more about
Vladimir Putin the report suggests that
he's the now the dominant player in the
region I think that's what you said
earlier if he is the dominant player in
the region is it a good thing or a bad
thing it's a terrible thing of course I
mean for one thing he doesn't have the
means to back up the power he's got
Russia has an economy the size of Spain
right they cannot control a world empire
which they're just falling into that
into their lap due to Western I don't
know not caring and and so he he can't
be what he wants to be in the end he's
he's managed to to assert I said but
it's just the beginning of further
complications further down the road
there's no way that Russia can impose
the kind of peace the kind of thing that
the Pax Americana once was excuse me and
he's definitely not a peacekeeper I mean
it was just that he yeah that's the only
peacekeeper I mean who was keeping peace
inside Syria everybody's just
intervening for his own interest and if
you talk about Russia you have to
mention that in it live during the last
few months and years lots of medical
places hospitals were attacked it's 54
hospitals since April and we have a very
very strong research by the New York
Times that in very detailed form proves
that there was an attack on
for hospitals within 12 hours by the
russian air force so this is very
crucial to understand how Vladimir Putin
leads a war against civilians you know
and it's not an anti-terror war and if
he's as bad as you are telling me here
if the influence of Vladimir Putin is as
baleful as you are making out why is
Turkey going so promiscuously to bed
with Vladimir Putin
I think Turkey has been pushed to do it
to do that in one way and Turkey pushed
by the West push by the NATO and push by
most importantly the United States
so whenever turkey wanted to get
something out of the US whether that be
the Patriot missile systems that was not
approved by the Obama administration
that turkey had to go to Russia knocked
on the door and said we want as 44 400
missile systems and it was only after
that that the u.s. decided to put
sanctions on Turkey because it might
potentially threaten the radar systems
of f-35 fighter jets that are coming up
so in all cases Turkey has been somehow
pushed today to the Russians to be able
to deal with its perceived security
threat that's wanting and on another
level Turkey has used this double game
as a leverage over time it also used
that during the Cold War where it was
aligned with NATO alliance and and and
Soviets were the enemy but Turkey some
sometimes was using that to get what it
wanted and Ireland has been playing this
card for for a good 20 years almost now
and as like the context is so
complicated right now in the ground that
like sometimes are done can I get what
he wants sometimes putting can I get
what he wants sometimes Trump cannot get
what he wants and I think they're just
trying to find a way to maneuver in this
making it and in this in this puzzle and
and find a way to get what they want but
the sad part is that it's not up to
trump anymore it's not up to the US
president anymore to counterbalance the
reactions coming up from the from the
u.s. itself so you've seen the
resolutions and the
decisions just passed over the past two
days in the from the House of
Representatives in the US and they have
the supermajority to put sanctions on
Turkey so Trump cannot be the gatekeeper
to veto these decisions anymore so right
Iran needs to find a way to convince not
only Trump but also other US
representatives to be able to stop that
huge sanctions coming up now because I
heard on himself his wealth is being
under investigation in the US or will be
I would argue there's a certain
chemistry between arrow and protein
right because these are two autocrats
very effectively pushing their own
interests you know and if you remember
it's four years ago that Turkey would
down Russia find a jet and everybody was
afraid of a new war and you had
sanctions very strong reactions from
Moscow and then have a year later they
were just you know two guys clapping
their shoulders said okay let's work
together again you know they're very
pragmatic they're very quick in their
decisions and this is what the West
especially Western Europe liberal
democracies cannot follow very
thoughtful and I'm wondering if there I
mean there are a growing number of
voices just to come back to Turkey
saying that turkey should somehow be I
mean there's no there's no way that it
can actually be done there's no
mechanism in NATO but somehow turkey
should be ejected from NATO I think we
would be the total wrong reaction I mean
look you know you don't have to say have
to like mr. add-on who who does nobody
does but no I mean he has many followers
no likes him in the West I mean he's
he's a pain but Turkey is an
indispensable ally it's a resilient
state it's not something that's gonna
fall apart like Syria or other Arab
countries or Iraq it's a resilient sate
it's been a bar walk against in in in
the Cold War in spite of double playing
and so on it's still crucial to solve
every problem gas in the in the eastern
Mediterranean the precise prescribes is
the refugee crisis there's no way if we
push turkey too far we're gonna you know
and an Ottawa knows this and he taunts
us with this but he's right he says okay
I'll let all the
Sirians is for three million I've got
I'll let them come to Europe do you want
that and he's right he's got us by the
short hairs and and I think you have to
recognize that and you have to try and
pull back Turkey into into the fold
rather than pushing it further into the
Russian camp but I think also we need to
discuss at least like you know pay
attention to the fact that these all
developments are happening in the shadow
of the domestic developments in the
countries and respect so like for
instance from the Turkish perspective in
Turkey Iran was not having his best days
just before the incursion he has been
losing ground
he's like former allies were turning
against him planning to form new parties
the opposition was on the rise he lost
so many municipalities and major cities
in the local elections so Aaron was in a
kind of a lonely position just before
the incursion and you know what happened
after the turkey started the incursion
apart from the pro-kurdish party
everybody line up lined up behind iron
and supported the encouraging including
the main opposition party and we have
everything that the foreign enemy - yeah
to consolidate his power or
reconsolidate his power we have a
refugee situation in Turkey with over 3
million Syrian refugees and third the
the Turkish population is no longer
happy about hosting over 3 million
refugees they're turning like you know
racist attacks on the rise in Turkey and
he needs to somehow find a way to divert
attention not only that you would
remember that when the incursion started
one of the discourses was that we're
going to resettle 1 million Syrian
refugees in these in these safe zones
which he said that we did in the west of
the Euphrates River after the last
operation and now this time in the east
of it but it's not going to happen
because of this all the all the
agreement that turkey struck with the US
and Russia so he needs to divert the
attention and we can also discuss about
the transposition in the US directions
we could go in here there's been a lot
of ground that we've covered where I can
see the clock is ticking though and it's
against her so I'm just wondering if I
might ask the following
to each of you and go and get a sort of
a relatively short answer which outcome
of the sort of the constellations the
coalitions the alliances that that are
in the offing in Syria that would be the
best outcome for the long-suffering
Syrian people Kristen oh the most
realistic one is not the one in the
interest of the Syrian people
so alliances are shifting in Syria which
is the very interesting part of it and
the new shift will be that a Dewan will
reconciliate with Assad this is just
happening and this is very clever by
Putin or the one with her sir yes and
Turkey was the country that mostly
supported Syrian opposition don't forget
that the Syrian uprising so now they
will switch because they will say from
our perspective Assad is the lesser of
two evils
we will rearrange ourselves with Syrian
troops along the border Russian military
police can even withdraw Putin is very
happy normal responsibilities there and
this will be a major shift and the price
will be paid by Syrian opposition or by
Syrian people that would long for
something called freedom and dignity
which is not there anymore so I would
argue that the West should not fall
through the strap of an international
diplomatic solution which is not taking
place because Assad will just keep his
power the way he did during the last
decades I second that opine and I think
that Ireland will genuinely have to find
a way to deal with Assad and it's
already happening and he's already
legitimizing Assad's future in Syria and
I agree with the argument that is the
lesser of two evils
like you know instead of having YPG
threatening Turkey let's deal with Assad
because Turkey already lost so many
things that it was trying to achieve in
Syria it's a catastrophe it's a
catastrophe for the primarily for the
Kurds secondly for all the rest of the
Syrians who wanted human dignity and
thirdly for the West which has lost any
influence it might have to project those
values let alone material interests so
I'm afraid you know I'd like I'd like to
project some hope but I don't see any
and there's a lot of tunnel at the end
of the light
person give us a little bit of hope you
got ten seconds yes I mean we should we
should focus on Syrian diaspora people
living in the airport
yes and stressing the fact that they
cannot go back to Assad Syria so work
with them here for a brighter future in
some time in the future okay thanks very
much for your insights all three of you
today for being here on to the year to
the point we've been discussing old
faces new alliances who will win the
battle for Syria thanks for being with
us
bye-bye and just
[Music]
[Music]
you